ほんじゃあ始めそうです皆さんお酒好きですか
あの僕お酒飲まないし全然のばないんですけど飲む人もいないんですけど飲む機会も
ないんですけどたまにはこうみんなでお酒を飲もうみたいな話になりまして今から
みんなでお酒を飲むんですけど02みんなどうぞいろんな工房&後日畑で上がるので
ぜひ見てみてくださいそんなみんなでお堀の中で一気の3位
池上ってマジで危ないんですよもちろん3戦の方お酒飲んじゃダメなので分からないと
思うんですけどあの1機のみって本当に切ってんであの僕が割とお酒の場な人誰だっけ
なんですよ本当に豊かなお酒がまで僕はまだみんながどういう動きをするかわかんない
ひょっとしたら突然表現しておられたらなぜかもしれないしてる全くわかんないです僕
としてはやっぱりお酒の場でしっかりしている人ってやっぱ素晴らしいんだっ
思ってましてただ僕は全くみんなかお酒とか全然飲みに行けないんでいまいちわから
ないことが多い
投票日で今日はもし肇社長が一気飲みをしたらみんながどういう反応するのかドッキリ
をやってみようと思いますって言ってここに3つほど準備しましたらパパワインの
ボトル2つ
日本酒1個で日本すらならねあああのぶどう酢 sm 度ず s を入れてきます山
待てどう見てもた可愛いんだけどやばいよねではよ
待ってやばいどう見てもまあ可愛い村で日本勢の中には普通に水がお水いただきます
はいと夕食準備できましたこれは完全に水
ブドウチーズぶどうジュースでございます私て俺の仲間たちは1機のみという危険で
こういう見たときどうするのか
方としてみようと思います夜にあるんでちょっとお風呂でも入ってマジ待ってろ
以下よ
じゃあちょっとあれば今売っ考えますよみんなはいけないかと1階です
どっ
うバンスやばいがある普通やら者やいや俺話じゃない
こちらどんどんいけないと思ってるんだって言ったらパズルんですよ
いやのやっぱり酒矩行
はい編さっきちゃうんですよ何そんな一歩先ます
山トレでパッケがバカだからジャージーガーってまぁハードレザーはめちゃめちゃ酒つ
えーから
うわぁ
一発決まってもらえてってことではご覧になりますか
ワイン飲んでも大丈夫まで大丈夫です本当に大丈夫ある場合は大丈夫だよ
です kazu さん mother
やはりどんないらっしゃなると思ってるですかこのれっぱ
アパ
英盤カラー
ありませんお酒声だけは皆さんは邪魔なんでは回まで一さんはマジこの24時の間に
これ一方が飲みます絶対の街や絶対がますマネー
ここでございますからね今マジでバー止めてよ本体運ばれるのとか
それじゃあ家一軒やりましょいきなよたっ敬愛し冷静
あのあくまでだって
昨日白菜と気に入ってたのを買うわー
はいおれもターンを一つなった街なんです
交え待って入ってソロじゃいつもねちょっとああっ83たんだよ俺何でもですそうです
ちょっということに
昨日さあシラフの時に入っ相性 pou dou dou
バーンでもこのだよねべがなんかああああ
ran
開けた上
んじゃってねーあー
長期が本当に申し訳で盆栽だ小うちのじいちゃんまた gpu さーああだ
今そろって食べちゃったよショボってなんてちょっといつメカって言うとなんか持っ
てるんだろうっわっ入れん
by どんどん販売しますはい日本絞って
源さんに嫌だけどこれがはじめ様だあれですあとでいいですこっちはわかった
こっちはちょっとっ
ねじゃあ普通肌後日だけなんだかを十分のでも開けばどぅ食べたらやるべきなんた方が
いいと思う
いっきして真っ暗4番パー5
亜鉛とリーダーがいるマジでとりあえずそっかいいじゃんねこれやめたらいいんじゃ1
回もすしやんって話やな
1回募集共通するぜなんか俺ございました
すげーまあをなああああ
ダメだって本当に言うというからビックリだねぇこの簡単何歳から
松てもう15分待ってください見てああああああっ
4魔獣マットねえ一般著三部はこれあげたー負けた彼が追加ダィスク30剤
さあじゃないじゃんいやはいじゃあもう者がんばろバルーンアース
1永江
dai はん
本当にダメお受験生
ai
dare you do do do do
ブーバーし
姉御センターからねぇ
ああああああ
さあポンドをもたげる飲み過ぎは呼べないから本当にも花
いややミャンマーでの時はから0
ana あれ俺ほしい
まあまあだめっちゃ誰やっぱり兼財務相メジャーや
本当に味玉塩これはそれなんかを買っちゃう殺すけどブーバーし
メン会社ではねえええ
あの伸びがあるパーティじゃないよね
水や見るわけさあ
me
aname
ni
me
[音楽]
あのー実はですね先ほど僕がどんなワインもわー
ただのブドウチーズですよええ
ちょうだい常設飲んで街でちょっと乗った
いやこれで部分ですがこれでみんながちゃんとしてる人だなっていうなら
証明できてらっしゃいた者